I'm the Felix Frankfurter professor of
law at Harvard Law School where I've
been teaching for
43 years.
Uh,
Larry Summers and I had a contest for
who got tenure,
youngest.
I had been the youngest professor to get
tenure at Harvard.
And then he beat me by three right
maths when he got,
I grew up in a frightened,
I was born
on the eve of the Holocaust,
1938.
Um,
my mother,
when my brother was born,
my mother kept saying she didn't know
whether she would have him in some
bunker in the basement somewhere.
We were all terrified of war and we were
all terrified of what was happening to
the Jewish community.
It was a powerless community at the
time.
Hard to imagine today,
but no influence in Congress,
no influence,
um,
really in any aspect of politics.
Um,
it was a community that really felt that
they were the guests in somebody else's
country.
They were second class citizens.
They were tolerated at best and they had
better behave.
Uh,
and it was a community of people who are
very patriotic,
quite conservative in their outlook
toward,
uh,
many things.
Um,
people sometimes stereotype the Jewish
communities being very radical,
a community.
And there are many secular Jews who were
radical during that period of time.
Some communists and socialists,
but in the Orthodox community,
I grew up in quite conservative,
quite patriotic.
Uh,
and um,
uh,
frightened is the word I think I would
use more than any other.
Uh,
the message I constantly got from my
parents and grandparents was shushed.
Still be quiet,
be quiet,
don't rock the boat,
don't do anything.
Don't make your hosts the real Americans
mad at you.
Uh,
whatever you do do quietly.
Obviously it didn't take with me and um,
I reacted.
Yeah,
I think too that
it's always nice to say your parents had
the greatest influence.
I would say.
In my case,
my father had very little influence on
my growing up.
He was very busy.
He had a small store which was not
particularly successful.
He was away all the time,
six days a week at work.
And the seventh day was the sabbath,
a day of rest where his job was to get
me up and drag me to the synagogue and
sit next to him.
While he went pray,
pray.
So the interaction wasn't particularly,
uh,
intimate or close.
My mother was somewhat ambitious for me
and she did defend me when I got into
trouble and kind of showed me a little
bit how you can stand up for rights.
But I think my greatest impact came from
teachers and peers.
Um,
particularly after I got out of the
yeshiva system.
I don't think the Jewish parochial
school system had much of an impact on
me.
I rebelled against it in that respect.
It did have an impact.
But when I got to Brooklyn College and
Yale Law School,
I was looking role models.
Uh,
I quickly learned there are no such
thing and that every hero has clay feet
and that everybody I respected,
Oh,
it was a flawed human being,
but I was able to learn quite a bit,
both intellectually and morally from
some of my mentors,
particularly the two,
uh,
judges I clerked for after I finished
law school or Justice Arthur Goldberg of
the United States Supreme Court and
Judge David Basil on,
they were both activists,
left liberal,
moderate left wing Jews,
labor union activists,
progressive's.
And they showed me how I could live a
Jewish life life in which I was not
embarrassed about my heritage,
where I could make the best of it and
use the best from it and still
contribute,
uh,
to America the world and not live in the
Shtetl in the ghetto from which,
uh,
I grew up
and grew out
would
probably be
one summer in camp.
I was,
um,
between my junior and senior year in
high school,
I was a terrible high school student.
Uh,
I got cs and b minuses.
In fact,
my yearbook originally said I was a good
speaker.
Some of your books had Dershowitz,
he has a mouth of webster and ahead of
clay.
It was cute.
And um,
my,
my rabbi said to me,
look,
Dershowitz,
you know,
you've got a good mouth on.
You're not a very good brain.
You've got to figure out a profession
that you can use your mouth a lot and
not your head.
Uh,
you should either be a lawyer or he said
a conservative rabbi.
He was,
of course an Orthodox rabbi and that was
the biggest put down you could,
you could have.
So I was put down a lot in high school
and there was this one guy in camp who
was four or five years older than me who
was a counselor.
And he picked me to play the leading
role in a play Cyrano de Bergerac by
Edmund Rustin.
Remember it as if it was today.
It was not only my long knows that
qualified me for the job,
but I was not a bad,
bad actor.
And uh,
and he was the first person,
he sat me down one day and said,
you know,
you're smart,
you have a very interesting mind,
you see things differently,
you're going to be a great student in
college.
I said,
come on,
I can't even get decent grades in a
third rate,
crummy high school.
How am I going to do well in college?
And he said,
the better the school you go to,
the better you'll do.
And he was absolutely right.
I went to Brooklyn College,
I did very,
very well.
And then I went to Yale law school and I
was first in my class.
Yale law school was one of the elite
institutions.
He was so right that the more
challenging the institution,
the better I was going to do.
And that was an insight that I just
didn't have.
Day.
I started this,
there was never any other path.
Me,
I was always a lawyer from the time I
was five or six years old.
My father,
although an uneducated didn't finish
high school,
um,
and it didn't read very much.
Uh,
uh,
worker.
Um,
he liked to stand up for the underdog
and he did convey that to me.
And my family had a tradition of
standing up for the underdog.
My father's family helped rescue people
from the Holocaust and social action and
social commitment was part of my
heritage in some respects.
But I always thought I was going to be a
lawyer and the only kind of a lawyer I
ever thought of was a criminal or who.
What else is there?
I'm not working for the government.
I wouldn't work for big government or
big corporations.
I had to be the lawyer for the underdog.
So I don't think I ever made a decision
to be a lawyer or a criminal lawyer.
It was just something that I always
thought I would do.
Others thought I would do what was
expected of me.
It was a role I played since the time I
was a child.